what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
kevin
samuels video video labeled modern women
scare their daughters before i start do
not forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification about my goal this
month is to get 20
000 subscribers and each and every one
of you helps me get to that goal
all right let's get this show on the
[Music]
road
[Music]
good how old are you i'm 20 28.
okey-dokey we're talking about keeping
versus getting getting versus keeping
okay let's do this what do you got
well i feel like in the black community
us black women we definitely have a
problem with being vulnerable and being
submissive
when the time is right with a guy so
it's hard to keep somebody when you're
constantly
bucking at them you can't let a man be a
man and you're trying to take that role
as well
so i agree with that um were you raised
with your mother and father
or just or you raised one parent like
most of us um
in the beginning for my first couple of
years it was my mom and my dad
and then they separated so it was more
of a co-parenting
thing and do you have any siblings
yeah two older brothers and now two
younger sisters
okay so um would you like to be married
one day
yeah are you sure
um it's i only say it like that because
again in today's day and age
it's very complicated not a lot of
people are getting
serious like that see
i am always my [ __ ] detective go
goes off on high alert when i hear women
say into this day and age
why because your evolutionary evolved to
be what you are
regardless of the day and age can a
female
of the species survive without the group
what she probably means though is like
now it's harder to get
men to marry and commit because i think
it was a lot more normal to get married
like
early and young like 50 years ago where
now
it's delayed no
women need men i agree
so is it that you don't want to be
married are you afraid
i'm afraid to get married again because
of that
so what are you afraid of
i wouldn't say the trials and
tribulations but that is part of it
because i've seen what my mom went
through
okay and i've always based off
like what what i like coming up i wanted
to do the opposite and
become the opposite and do you now
without getting too personal
uh will your mother and father's
situation
money motivated were they like the most
people or was there like
domestic violence where there was real
violence or drugs or anything involved
um i could say it was a mixture of
financial problems
um and also
infidelity okay do respect
this is why i think women
go or wrong i said it before
that's nearly a child's place
but how do you how do you know but my
thing is unless you walked in on
your your mother or father with somebody
you wouldn't know they're cheating i
actually agree
i i don't think it's good on the parents
to like talk about each other to the kid
it's really hard
i would say not to especially when the
kids are older like a lot of parents
do it but um
i think you should respect the mother
the father of your kids enough not to
talk smack
to your kids about them
uh even like i heard this song the other
day it was about lives from a rapper i
don't know which one but he was
trashing and just dissing the mother of
his kid and saying all these bad things
about her
and i was just thinking like even if she
was that awful
now you have the kid having to endure on
a public platform
his parents like fighting and now you're
like putting the kid
through that and i was thinking just how
selfish that really was of the guy who
made the song
if the money problems why do you know if
they didn't
share that with you and and i was going
to say that unfortunately it was shared
with me and i did not ask for that
information
which parents does your mother share
with you
okay um and see
this is the burden of sharing
this kind of stuff with kids you said
they were co-parents
did your mother remarry no my dad
married definitely okay
but my mom didn't so the person that had
who had infidelity which is your father
or your mother
it was my dad okay but he remarried
yeah how did you find out about the
infidelity who told you that
my dad okay did he tell you that
that is the reason that they're no
longer married
all right so i'll give a little leeway a
parent has to give a reason why the kids
are divorced
i wouldn't have gone to that level of
detail but your father
remarried your mother did you ever see
her dating anybody
yeah um no yes i did
i i definitely did and that was kind of
the problem for me growing up
her boyfriend what i what i seen it
wasn't a great example
so i again so i tried to just do that
she seems really nice actually
like she seems very level-headed i bet
she gets married opposite of what i've
seen
and okay well i try to stay away from
one one big problem is people of this
generation involve kids and grown folks
business and it puts you
so this is where therapy comes into but
here's the reality
your mother and father's problems don't
sound like anything that
you can't find in any neighborhood in
this world exactly or
or any time period in history if you
don't get married
uh 28 did you go to college yes what's
your degree in
business administration i'm going for my
bachelor's next
okay so what do you plan on doing for
profession
um i want to work in a recording label
as in the marketing theme that's what
i'm going for my bachelor's for
marketing
and okay so how much money how much do
you think you will earn
annually at the height of your career
at the height i would hope
i would hope at least
um over 50 000 a year i would hope
okay i ran in a random simulation
that if a woman grant
was working a job making 50 000 a year
from 25 to age 55
no stops no breaks and received a cost
of living
raise three percent every year
25 to 65 and she retired at 65
and had a life expectancy to 85 that
means she had to live 20 years
that woman would be would have a
shortfall
of almost 800 000 in her retirement
it's gonna take 2.9 million dollars to
live from 65 to 85
what i'm saying young lady is you're
going to college
and doing all this work to get a middle
income job
and if you don't marry who's going to
pay your bills and help you
in your in your golden years if you
don't have a husband
insurance children because
dogs can't do it i've never thought
about that
damn i guess that's the one thing you
don't think about about living that long
your girlfriends can't yeah so the fear
of being married
marriage i need you and i need women to
hear
if you are an average earner marriage is
not an option
it is a necessity and it has been
marketed to you as an
option to be chosen to not do out of
fear
wow wow i never thought about it that
way
well then what's the option after you're
45
and you're just making 50 000 a year
that ain't no that ain't no money
yeah no it's not so i know i i
completely agree i believe
in there needs to be a man in the house
and there needs to be gender roles
i believe in all that it's just
i don't know what should be scary
it's doing it alone no what should be
scary is
trying to live from 65 to 85.
you will need 2.9 million dollars
damn i think i need you to understand
how big of a number that
is older women older people
cost more true your insurance your
medications all these things you cost
more oh my god
i don't like this so what should be
scary is the notion if
i don't have a husband then you what are
you gonna do
go live with your girlfriend or your
sister because you're gonna have to
that's what's happening right now women
are starting to end up living with other
women
and i was just i was watching your life
and i said that to my friend i was like
i was saying a lot of date and nowadays
a lot of people just rather roommate and
it's
it's weird well well it's because you
ladies are the ones that
have our divorce rate in our community
is approaching 60
but almost 90 of the voices in the black
community are found by black women
80 of divorces are found by women
women are not staying in relationships
anywhere
when a divorce happens it's usually the
woman filing
and why are women filing because you've
been told
that it's life is better single
or you could have other options but if
the way you talked about it you're
afraid of marriage
i want a world to where women like you
are far more afraid to be single living
on cat food
because i'm afraid of both honestly but
i'm more afraid of
being by myself for sure all right yeah
i i would agree i wouldn't say i'm
afraid of getting married but i think
every girl has
a fear at some level of like winding up
by themselves
well if that's the case then what are
you doing to
overcome your negative
programming in your childhood and your
because you're 28 years old man
you are firmly in the danger zone yeah i
know
you're going to hit the wall in two
years and you don't
time is starting to run out i i know
i was just telling my friend that your
friend but i'm talking to you i can't
talk
so this is why i talk about the danger
zone this is when
you ladies need to really get real
crystal clear on what you want
and do something about it because at 35
options start getting taken off the
table
have you ever seen a show called the
golden girls no
okay you're dating who go ahead i'm i'm
dating someone right now he does live in
a difference
oh my god i forgot
this is gonna sound so bad my parents
are rich i don't have to
date but
i don't have to worry about that i'm
sorry i'm sorry it's just true
this is true was the last time you had a
relationship
about five years ago that's not
acceptable
i know i didn't want to say a
how does the man out of state
he's younger than me then obviously it's
not real
you're playing and this is why i'm being
very serious you don't have time to play
this is not a joke to me it's not a game
to me
i'm looking at another statistic another
black woman
who is likely going to be unmarried no
children no
family another
not made family because you ladies
you said you're going to go to college
right yes i'm going for my bachelor's
to go make fifty thousand dollars in
marketing
i would feel like that i would probably
start with that
now that
corporate sales marketing you need to
see this is what i mean
black remember when i was black men what
i said when black women
don't know what to do they run school
school is the black woman's
husband if the job ain't that's why
y'all run
you run to school like it's like it's
god like it's g
i'm going hide in school go spend
money to get a degree in communications
and marketing
which is a worthless degree
it's worthless it's
worthless yeah so i would actually agree
getting a business degree
if i had to do it over again
i mean i might might have done the same
thing only because i played college
sports and that
was an experience like i cherish a lot
but if i if i wasn't an athlete i
definitely
would not recommend college science
engineering technology man
business administration business
marketing business administration
business management marketing
communications all worthless
you go get an entry-level job somewhere
it is paying about 30
000 35 000 entry level at 30 years old
but you got to go into debt to do that
true
so i'm i am more disturbed that
black women have been told that that
makes the most
sense to go into college debt
and to go make get your head right and
become a wife
and find a husband
y'all prepare to live life alone
that's what you're doing whether you
admit it or not i got it i have a
relationship with five years i got a
long-distance relationship
i'm gonna go to college so i can use
college as a shield to keep men away
from me
and i am going to and then i'll say i'm
busy doing this so-called recording job
making fifty thousand dollars a year and
you look up and you're 50 years old
and when no i
i i now that you say it it's it's but
the fact that matters that's the thing
i think kevin samuels genuinely has good
intentions
um sometimes it gets lost in his
delivery but i don't even
mind his delivery so much because i
don't think she would have the same
realization or wake-up call if he didn't
phrase it like that
i'm saying it and i'm the only person to
sing the golden girls
four elderly women i've seen that okay
i've never watched the show but i've
definitely this is this is the
i'm gonna break this down tomorrow this
is this is how this is black woman's
future
because there is absolutely no reason
for you
for i'm gonna just say this man what you
saw
i can't tell you your pain but it
doesn't sound abnormal
but but to have it but to have you
almost
it's like black women have relationship
anaphylactic shock
to all my medical people you know what
i'm talking about black women have
anaphylactic shock when it comes to men
black men y'all have a hyper allergic
relate
a hyper allergic reaction to commitment
with a black man
anaphylactic shock is when you see
somebody get stung by a bee and they die
no that's how y'all connect with a
marriage or a relationship oh god
i saw something happen oh i was going to
kill me i had to go to college
thank you very much you can't avoid
really well
you want to avoid relationship you
better be making high six figures
no i'm not the hope it comes down i'm
definitely not trying to avoid it
i'm definitely trying to work through it
and get better well the thing is
i hear you say that now but i don't i
don't hear anything in your life before
this
i hear college and and and just i watch
youtube videos
now i if you're really trying to work to
get it better there'll be counseling
maybe therapy there be
you'd be investing money and trying to
get my mind right to understand why
i look around and i see my counterparts
my non-black counterparts are my age
and over half of them are married even
they got little bitty rings on their
marriage
i agree with the therapy i even spoke
with my mom about that
and again with the black community i
don't know why but therapy is looked
down upon so when
you came okay stop talking to your mama
definitely because i know that's one of
my problems i know
i know i know you're a grown damn woman
stop talking to your mama stop looking
for
permission to get your [ __ ] together
you're right
because your mama due respect is not the
one you got to be married your father
so whether he cheated or not or whatever
he's gone about his business
and unfortunately the world likes y'all
single
alone and for and uh spending money
misery loves company funny that's the
world likes it that way
so i wonder if you'll see um
like women as they get like past the age
of 45 and like 50s 60s if they end up
getting
married to you know because even if a
girl is like 45 she could still marry a
guy that's 55 or 60.
i know like he doesn't necessarily need
to be the high
value man that you guys all talk about i
wonder if like women will have this
epiphany and then later
switch it up and like actually get
married like his mom did
if you're looking for what did i say
single women keep women single
it's because the anaphylactic shock
responds to
to com to a marriage yeah so it's not
the current state of men it's the
current state of
women i agree because
by your own experience your damn be
married right yes
your mom had the same opportunities out
in the market
definitely dead i appreciate it thank
you
bye-bye kevin samuels is actually
nice i don't that was actually a really
nice conversation
um i definitely did not think about what
he was talking about with the
like if a girl is making 50 000 up to a
certain
age that she's not gonna have enough
money to live
um past 65. i literally never thought
about that
um so that was a really that was a
really good point i wonder
what how much money she would have to
make in order to be okay like past a
certain age
let me know if you know the answer to
that in the comments don't forget
subscribe to the channel
bring that notification bell i will talk
to you guys
next time